ce chronomètre que vous venez de voir
démarrer est un symbole chaque jour dans
toutes les villes de france
ceux qui se rendent à leur travail en
voiture se disent aujourd'hui combien de
temps vais-je m
car il ya toujours les feux les
embouteillages l'imprévu le chronomètre
qui tourne dans cette voiture va nous
indiquer le temps mis pour faire dans
paris un parcours très simple les 13
kilomètres qui séparent le pont
d'auteuil du pont de bercy sur les quais
de la rive droite
si nous avons pris ce parcours c'est
parce qu'il va changer
au lieu d'être une série de rue et de
quais avec des feux rouges et des
croisements
il va devenir une seule voie express
sans feu rouge sans croisement
ce ne sera pas une autoroute mais une
voie rapide permettant d'arriver vite
dans le centre de paris et au lieu des
26 minutes 30 secondes mise en plein
mois de juillet comme vous allez le voir
pour faire ce trajet il faudra alors
environ un quart d'heure les parisiens
ont déjà baptisé cette voix haute aux
berges mais ce n'est pas exact en effet
sur 13 km de voies express il n'y aura
que 2 km vraiment sur berge
pour le reste la voie empruntera le
trajet actuel le sens favoriser sera
surtout celui de west en est mais
certains passages resteront comme en ce
moment à double sens
dans quelques instants nous allons
arriver au pont de bercy ce parcours
fait en plein mois de juillet a été
rapide mais imaginez le un vendredi de
novembre à six heures du soir
c'est pour cela que le promoteur de
cette voie express monsieur à ce picard
préfet de la seine en a décidé la mise
en chantier
monsieur le préfet pourquoi cette voie
express dans pareil pour faciliter la
circulation automobile et pour supprimer
23,3 mans c'est à dire 23 feu rouge
cela facilitera la circulation non
seulement dans le sens est ouest deux au
centre de paris
mais par la suppression de ces
croisements puisque l'on passera soit en
souterrain soit en berge
cela facilitera également la circulation
nord-sud et sud-nord
voilà la raison d'être de cette voie
express
examinons la maintenant en détail il va
falloir construire des berges 3 et des
souterrains pour supprimer les
carrefours et les feux et devant le
louvre pour ne pas abîmer la
merveilleuse perspective la voie express
va passer sous le quai actuel monsieur
clergeau ans directeur général des
services techniques du département de la
seine nous détaille tous ces ouvrages
d'art ces temps
passage souterrain pratiquement comme
les autres passages souterrains vous
avez dans paris avec simplement que
cette particularité qu'il permettra le
franchissement à niveaux différents de
deux ponts successifs le pont alexandre
iii le pont des invalides et le pont
alexandre iii
cet ouvrage qui aura environ 400 mètres
de longueur
imposera quelques modifications en
surface les armes
côté fleurs ne sont pas du tout touché
et du côté et ceux qui sont le plus
rapproché des maisons également y aura
simplement un élargissement si vous
voulez de la voix et report des arbres à
quelques mètres en arrière de part et
d'autre la place de la concorde place de
la concorde il va y avoir un sous
terrain normal pour franchir pour passer
en dessous de la voie venant du pont de
la concorde mais il ya aussi un
raccordement avec les champs-elysées cet
ouvrage est donc déjà beaucoup plus
important cet ouvrage est dans
l'ensemble pas plus important il est un
peu plus complexe puisque comme vous
venez de l'indiquer il y a direction
générale le long des quais qui est le
passage souterrain principal c'est
d'autres ouvrages partant prenons plutôt
le débit le trafic descendants de
l'avenue des champs elysées de façon à
éviter des points de conflit que tous
les parisiens connaissent sur la place
de la concorde
la partie la plus onéreuse de de toute
cette voie express c'est évidemment le
souterrain de l'ovv qui va voir 800
mètres de longueur n'est ce pas et dont
la ventilation sera assurée par un
certain nombre de baies donnant
directement sur le fleuve c'est une
tranchée couverte c'est à dire que l'
ouvrage sera réalisé à ciel ouvert est
ensuite couvert c'est l'aspect final
sera le souterrain cela donc prendre
toute la place ce qui posera des
problèmes sérieux
il est bien évident que il y aura une
gêne pour la circulation
mais il faudra que les automobilistes
pense qu'ensuite ils auront les très
gros avantage est fort alors demandé un
petit peu de patience
c'est ici exactement que ressortira le
souterrain du louvre et la voix
continuera ensuite sur berge mais que
vont dire de tout cela les habitués des
berges de la seine les mères de famille
qui venait y promener leurs enfants les
amateurs de solitude et de tranquillité
qui s'y reposer les peintres les
retraités qui venez flâner avec leurs
chiens les clochards et les amateurs de
vannes soleil à tous nous avons posé la
question que pensez vous de la
construction de cette voie sur berge et
monsieur à spycker répondra ensuite à
leurs critiques un peu moins agréable
quand même parce que il y aura beaucoup
plus de voitures il ya un tire pas mal
bouffe est alors encore plus ça fera du
bruit c'est dommage ici on reviendrait
pourquoi un autre quoi on change un pas
ça changera pas mais vous pourrez plus
dormir ici comme ailleurs ça manque de
quoi maintenant d'ici là dans ma chambre
oh ben écoutez pour 55 prendre métro et
55 points poule retour c'est pas
tellement cher on va la campagne avec la
vie actuelle
portable ou seulement pour nous
les autres nations sont reposés ont
choisi la scène
spirou tranquille
votre vie un autre coin c'est très
difficile parce que
qu'elle nous
mon seul et tranquille
je crois que vous aurez du mal à ce
moment-là à promener vos chiens bah oui
ça sera bien embêtant couru plus pour
nous aussi parce que c'était une petite
promenade assez pittoresque quand même
les quais de la seine c'est ce qui a
mieux les pêcheurs ont pas tous souhaité
ou quoi en principe vous pourrez
continuer il restera un emplacement pour
les titres abc il sera certainement pas
bien large a pris avec les voitures qui
passeront ce sera bien délicat de les
laisser en liberté un mais vous avez une
voiture
oui aussi non monsieur mois ne rangez
pas de voiture et vous pourtant où
malgré votre voiture vous êtes content
ah oui ouaga membres très chic ont hélas
toute la poésie 120 vous aimez ce coin
des berges au château on est un jeu de
paris je les peins depuis qu'elle mente
annie dupuy attendant qu'une pente en
accueillant mais c'est le chanteur robin
et ma foi la fenice dans une premier
temps vous êtes pour cette autoroute non
touchés tout repos déjà reprendre
marcelo pour marissa plutôt détruit
l'atmosphère qu'il y avait avant tout
est détruit envoyait
détruis du commun a tout détruit
ce serait bien de manse nous nous sommes
efforcés dans la mise au point de ce
projet de respecter à la fois des
monuments historiques et les berges
nous utilisons purement et simplement
les berges existantes et un seul endroit
nous construisons les 900 mètres de
berges qui manquent
nous respectons tous les arbres regardez
ici vous avez à la fois des arbres le
long des quais verticaux et vous avez ce
soir avec ses traits au lisa arbres le
soir de l'hôtel de ville
eh bien nous ne coupons pas bien entendu
les arbres le long des quais et quant au
square de l'hôtel de ville
non seulement nous le conservons non
seulement nous le protégeons mais nous
arrivons un quadruplé la superficie et
les promeneurs pourront rejoindre ce
parc ce soir plutôt ainsi augmenté par
une passerelle qui passera au dessus de
la voie sur berge
quand verrons-nous cette auberge
terminée vers les milieux de 1967 et les
travaux vont commencer comme tu vois que
je pense que les travaux vont commencer
à la fin de l'année et je pense que les
trois souterrains seront en chantier
dans le milieu de l'année prochaine